live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsay personality George
Campbell joined this hour by Rachel Cruz
best-selling author and co-host not only
today of the Ramsay show but also my
co-host on Smart money happy hour so be
sure to check that out we're having a
good time over there as well a lot of
levity a lot of fun and we try to bring
that to the show as well so it's a free
call at triple eight eight two five five
two two five so you jump on the lines
and we'll talk about your life and your
money Natalie kicks us off in Buffalo
New York Natalie welcome to the show
hi thank you for having me absolutely
how can Rachel and I help
and I do qualify for the public loan
service for gymnast so I've been trying
to really aggressively pay off the loans
I make my net income
is about 120 000 a year so I've been
kind of pouring as much money as I can
into my low to try to get them out but
at the same time
the loans are going like they're due to
be forgiven in four more years I already
have six years I qualify it would just
be four or more years before there's
supposed to disappear
um I'm also trying to like stay for a
down payment on a house so I was trying
to see if I could put some of my money
into a savings account or a CD to try to
get enough money for a down payment
rather than towards my loans
Natalie what was your degree in for four
hundred thousand dollars
I'm a physician okay and you're making
120 do you see your income going up
anytime soon
so that's like after taxes and
everything
um not anytime soon maybe like on a
yearly basis
okay so you're probably making closer to
200 or so gross
exactly yes like 213 or so okay well
first and foremost no I would not be
saving for a house Natalie until you get
all of this situated because it gets it
gets in a really tough position when
people go and purchase something like a
home which is for most people you know
their largest financial purchase
and then you still have this debt which
is basically a mortgage you know that I
mean like it's just it's a lot not that
you can't get out of it I wanted to
sound hopeless but the weight of the
amount that you owe
um plus a mortgage on top of that and
everything I we don't suggest
getting a mortgage until you're debt
free and have an emergency fund so I
would be if I were you yeah working to
pay this off but you said you're part of
that of the loan forgiveness program and
it and you think in four years is that
because I think from a lot of from what
we've read and researched and Christina
Ellis who's
um really the expert when it comes to
student loans and student loan
forgiveness I mean the the ratio the
percentage still is so low the
percentage that actually get it that
actually get it yes abysmally low and
you know I hope that you are in there
and I hope it works out but we always
have to think about what if it doesn't
because if you don't make all these
payments perfectly the whole thing
resets and we just don't know what the
next four years of your life looks like
and the other side of this are you
wanting to purposefully work in the
public sector
so right now I mean kind of everywhere
I've had a job is just a mess Vector
um so I was thinking of just sitting
there for at least until you know for
four more years just to in case I do
qualify to to do that yeah I mean that's
the part that scares me is you kind of
put your life on hold and you go I'm
just gonna settle and be comfortable
because I'm gonna hope that this works
out versus you jumping into the private
sector and making you know who knows a
hundred thousand dollars more which is a
possibility and you go oh I guess I
don't need the government to forgive
this after all I can take control of
this and so I'm not anti you hanging on
for four years but like Rachel said I
would also not be making giant Financial
moves jumping into a house and all of a
sudden the Forgiveness didn't work out
and now you still have a pile of loans
sitting there
right I guess all my life I've just been
renting an apartment and I feel like my
money's not really going anywhere and I
thought it would be a good investment
but yeah and it yeah and you're exactly
right though it would be and I think you
know real estate and owning a home is
something yeah we definitely want for
everyone but just with your current
situation and this amount of debt but
the great thing is Natalie you know if
you do what George says and just kind of
dream a little bit and say Hey what if I
go into the private sector how much can
I make and how much you know would it
take because you could have a really big
shovel you have a big you know hole if
you will with that 400 000 but you could
also get a massive shovel and and knock
this out in two years I mean you know if
you made you know 350 yeah 350 and it's
like man you really could you could make
a huge dent in a quick period of time
um so that's what I would do and too
Natalie there's um almost this mindset
to have when it comes to your money and
I think you know majority of the parts
of your life if you just of you owning
it you know and taking control and
instead of waiting on a program or
waiting on a system to come in and fix
it for you for you to say okay I signed
up for these loans this is the career
path I wanted and I bet you're fantastic
a fantastic physician and you're going
to be able to help and you are helping
you know tons of people so it's such
wonderful work that you're in
um and to say I'm going to just take
care of my life and my money and it's
going to be up to me and when you have
that mindset on something as big as
student loans and student loan
forgiveness and this is kind of the same
conversation we're having people out
there that are waiting on the current
system you know to get into place
because they want someone's forgiven and
so it's just that mindset shift and when
you start to actually take control of of
your life things just move like the
progress of what you do you just take
ownership and then that bleeds into
other areas of your life too so that's
that's kind of our attitude when it
comes to our money is is not waiting on
someone else or another program to
fix it and wait for years where you
could do you could do a lot Natalie you
really could and I believe you can yeah
so you know I'm not going to give you
advice today to say go do this or go do
that but we hopefully gave you enough to
chew on to kind of thumb through this
and when people are you know over
halfway into this Rachel it's hard to go
like okay like in four years it could be
gone you know what that's a lot of money
I'm gonna be a little bit more black and
white than you George okay I would tell
her I would tell her go to the private
sector unless she feels called if
there's like this like and that was like
why to the public but if it's not if
you're doing the public just to get the
loans forgiven in four years I'd scratch
it and I would say go to the private
sector you can serve there really well
help a lot of people
just grab on your and then and then
saving up for a house Natalie with that
income with no payments no debt I'm like
oh my gosh you could save up for an
incredible quickly for a down payment
like all 20 years in the private sector
yes I mean in the next five years now
your life could look so different so if
I were in your shoes that's what I would
do that's a good word and uh go check
out our borrowed future documentary it's
free on YouTube uh and I think that will
it maybe inspire you in some ways as we
dig into this whole student loan crisis
the further education conversation it's
good stuff and while we're on this
thread Rachel talking about taking
control I want to mention that we have
launched our Building Wealth events and
that's kind of what it's all about we're
telling people hey you don't have to
wait on the economy on the White House
to take control of your money and build
wealth and so a general admission passes
for this event are just 39 bucks until
December 5th so that's early bird
pricing it's going to be Dave Ramsey Dr
John deloney Ken Coleman myself Rachel
Cruz we're going to kind of switch off
at these events across the country we're
kicking it off January 12th in Nashville
Tennessee then we're going going to
Indianapolis in February Austin in
February Salt Lake City in April and
Anaheim California on May 2nd we're
going to show you how to inflation proof
your money build lasting wealth
and how to apply these principles to
your life in a way that is real so early
bird pricing ends Monday do not miss
this get your general admission pass for
just 39 bucks today go to
ramseysolutions.com events that's
ramseysolutions.com events don't wait on
anyone to get control of your life and
especially your money this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George Campbell Join This Hour by Rachel
Cruz well it's been an amazing week of
Ramsay shows so far appreciate all of
you calling in and trusting us with your
biggest life and money questions and a
lot of tough family situations going on
right now calls about paying back a
strange parents loan taking estranged
children out of the will moving on after
a divorce setting boundaries around
holidays and Christmas gifts and travel
giving money to kids there's so much
relational and money conversations
happening right now Rachel yes and yeah
this week it was just magnified it felt
like there was a lot holidays will bring
that out I guess so on top of that we
had some amazing Dave rants which we all
love I know you do as listeners on
annuities gazelle intensity on eating
out I had a viral Tick Tock video about
how eating out is more expensive than
eating because I heard about this what
happened people were just saying your
numbers are so wrong you can't eat at
home
average meal eating at home about four
bucks per serving I think I need to make
that clear average meal eating out about
13 bucks everyone they're like my eggs
are 13 oh my gosh you can't and so it's
just a very very upset you George and
Dave's reaction I mean he was at level
10 the whole time you gotta go check
that one out he also had a great rant
about Bitcoin Bros uh as more and more
crypto
um you know coins are collapsing
companies collapsing and uh even some
current event stuff student loan
forgiveness has been a Hot Topic and all
these crypto exchanges failing so a lot
of good calls good content go check it
out you can do that go back and listen
to podcasts check out the Ramsay Show
YouTube channel all about the highlights
and if you do like the show if you're an
avid listener you love it please
consider subscribing leaving a review
and especially this share it with
someone who needs to hear it most people
these days Rachel they've got the
Rolodex full when it comes to shows the
only way they're gonna add one in or
swap one out is for a friend to say Hey
you really need to check out the Ramsay
show and so Cinema specific episode that
you really enjoyed yeah that's super
helpful to help us make more impact
across the country back to the phones we
go the number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five Jerry is calling
in from Indianapolis Jerry welcome to
the show
hi thank you absolutely how can we help
um first of all God bless you for taking
my call and um I basically owe about 50
000 on my home the price is at about 180
and my question is
um should I sell it should I keep it or
should I because I'm getting ready to be
an operations manager for an Airbnb or
turn it into a b b and buy a camper whoa
so what's driving these decisions
um well just because
I intent over that
um to get back and then what but then
you need to go live somewhere else and
the Market's still hot and so you'd have
to go buy something just as expensive if
not more expensive or a camper or a
camper and so what's driving you to get
the camper
well I have only a 15 year old at home
so
um we live in a small home anyway so it
wouldn't be a really big adjustment for
us
Jerry is the um is the mortgage payment
what what is it compared to your income
is it overwhelming or is it doable is it
less than that 25 that we talk about
oh yeah okay
um I mean I can give you my opinion
without asking any more follow-up
questions shorts unless you have any but
I mean I mean if I were you Jerry I
would stay in the home I mean the home
is only going to continue to go up in
value uh owning real estate is just a
great investment I mean it's something
that I think is part of your net worth
it's something that continues to go up
um I think we're now at the point that I
think everyone realizes it's not a
bubble it's not going to burst everyone
was nervous about that about 12 months
ago nine months ago
um so where you're at in equity is is
great I mean that's for your for you
know on your side uh when it comes to
stuff so so moving into
um you know a smaller home or camper I
mean you can if you that's what you want
to do but you don't need to financially
and in fact staying in real estate I
think is just a it's a great investment
do you have any other debts
um I owe a truck payment that's about 30
000. about 30 how much do you make a
year
um with my husband about 90 about 90
okay
um I'd focus on paying off that truck
and I'd stay put where I'm at I just I
don't see this as a problem and so we're
trying to solve a non-existent problem
because once you're in the camper when
now the camper is going down in value
you no longer have an asset and the
camper is still a short-term solution we
can't live in a camper forever and so I
just don't see the the reason to make a
big Financial move like this when you
don't have to so I'd be about the
business of paying off the truck then be
about the business of paying off the
mortgage and now we have a fully paid
for home that maybe we can upgrade and
pay cash later on down the road
okay sounds great appreciate your guys's
goodbye yeah absolutely thanks for
calling Jerry good stuff all right Kevin
joins us up next in Irvine California
Kevin welcome to the Ramsay show
thanks George great to be here well it's
great to have you how can we help today
so I've never had life insurance my wife
has never had life insurance we've never
been dependent upon each other's income
our assumption is essentially if one of
us died the other would be just fine
with the money they were making plus
whatever was in the retirement account
of the person who died but now with
three factors changing things up I'm
starting to reassess that uh first
factor is inflation has made our cost of
living go up a bit second factor is the
stock market being down the money in our
accounts is a lot less than it was and
third factor is we just found out that
we're pregnant so oh congratulations
what my responsibilities are that'll do
it won't it
that's great your Factor's right there
exactly why we tell every human being to
get life insurance if there's someone
else in the picture because we don't
know what life's going to throw at us
and if for God forbid my spouse died I
don't want to have to go straight back
to work because I need that paycheck I
want to have space to grieve I want to
have money in the bank to know that I'm
covered on that area so that I have that
space emotionally and so that's one
major reason to have it in place so I
would absolutely get life insurance for
both of you in place get a term life
policy that is worth 10 to 12 times your
income especially as you bring a little
one into the world yeah are you guys
both pretty healthy Kevin pretty you
know
would you say health-wise I think so for
sure yeah yeah totally well how old are
you guys
I'm 34 she's 32. and do you mind if I
give you my numbers real quick yeah
please
yeah so we have a paid for home it was
worth 5 45 when we bought it it's
probably around 800 now depending on if
Zillow is accurate that's great and then
in my retirement accounts
um before everything took a downturn it
was around
half a million and our living expenses
after having the house paid off was
roughly like 40 000 a year because you
know no mortgage payment payment you can
live a lot more cheaply yeah so my my
numbers were essentially that because I
have half a million in my retirement if
I you know bite the dust a little too
early then my wife can easily live off
of 10 of that half a million
um but again the living expenses have
gone up a little I'm not entirely sure
how much because it seems to change yes
to week to month yeah and I'm not sure
with the Baby Come Along coming along
what that would mean also and then if
she were to die then I would be in a
little bit of a world of hurt because I
couldn't get to my retirement funds and
she has 55 in hers and which would be
fine if there wasn't a baby in the mix
but if there's a baby then I'll have to
worry about child care and stuff sure
sure well let me tell you this Kevin I
mean yes when you look at the numbers
and everything that you're saying could
you technically be self-insured uh I
mean yeah you guys have a paid for else
you have great you know great retirement
like you said she doesn't have as much
so yeah uh you're the one that you know
would be the one that you're like oh
gosh
um but I in my opinion term life as long
as you're healthy and you're more on
that you know the younger end of the
spectrum it's so inexpensive like my
husband and I we just upped ours
probably 18 months ago maybe two years
ago
um and we're I mean I would say we would
technically be self-insured um you know
we're kind of to the point that we're
like okay we're on maybe step seven and
we might be fine but I'm like it's just
so cheap that apartment's like yeah I
kind of just like to have it like just
in case that I'm like okay it's just
there because it's so inexpensive and as
it starts raising where you're like hey
that's just it's just not a good use of
our money anymore because your
retirement's grown you guys again uh
maybe in a different a different season
then you could look at saying yeah
self-insured but I I would still do it
just because it's so inexpensive but
maybe that's the security part of me as
a woman where I'm like it's that extra
extra safety net that just feels nice to
have yes 10 to 12 times your income get
a 15 or 20 year policy you're going to
sleep better at night and by the way if
you're a stay-at-home parent you
especially need insurance just because
you don't have a paycheck doesn't mean
that if you need to be replaced it would
take 17 people that's a lot of money
about half a million dollars on a
stay-at-home parent that's what you need
get this in place today you can go check
out our friends at Xander Insurance
that's where me and Rachel have ours
through and they will take good care of
you this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined by Rachel Cruz this hour
you can give us a call at triple eight
eight two five five two two five if you
want to talk about your life and your
money well Rachel I've been tagged in
about a thousand of these Spotify
wrapped Instagram stories I know isn't
it and what's so cool to see is how many
people have been checking out the Ramsay
network shows not just the Ramsey show
but the Dr John deloney show the Ken
Coleman show the Rachel Cruz show smart
money happy hour and a Jacob D emailed
in with subject line I think I have a
Ramsay show addiction and his top four
podcast Ramsay show the Dr John deloney
show trooc crime garage followed by
smart money happy hour there you go so
thank you Jacob uh for being such an
intent listener of all of our shows and
thank you all for listening for sharing
that on Instagram it helps us spread the
word about the show and impact more
people and that Spotify rap's hilarious
Rachel they're like this is so accurate
it's like yeah it's literally data it's
literally it's literally
we know that you listen to the Taylor
Swift album 48 times in the past week so
good that was a personal attack on me
Rachel fire album
all right let's go to the phones Carrie
joins us all the way in Anchorage Alaska
Carrie welcome to the show
hello thank you for taking my call you
are so happy to be so cold right now how
are you doing
folks I love it that's the resilient
Alaskan Vibe we need today how can we
help that is true well I just had a few
questions
um this year had a lot of changes I sold
a condo that I had owned for 10 plus
years and bought a home and I also got
engaged and so now here I am with a
fiance with a home and I have a home and
we're kind of just in that spot where
I was able to rent my house out
um you know I'm
and and I don't know if I'm doing the
right thing or come when the lease you
know
um is up should I rent it out again do I
need to think about just selling my
house or do we keep it and so
yes you guys will be moving into his
place
we are okay and so then you have your
house still it's rent it you're gonna
rinse it or it's renting now
um do you guys have any debt what will
your financial situation be when you
guys get married what would be your
combined income
uh it'll be about
probably about 400. okay
and do you guys have any debt
uh the uh the only debt that I have is
my mortgage okay does he will he have
any
no just his mortgage as well okay and
how much is his mortgage
you know it's about 1800.
what's left total on the loan
uh I'm not exactly sure on the number
but it's definitely under 200 000. okay
cool probably under 150 000. and how
about you in your house well so my
payment is about 2200 and I just closed
on the home in May okay and how much do
you have left on the mortgage three
about 360. 360. okay what's it worth if
you sold to today
about the same yeah I but again with the
market doing what they're doing
I would think I would get what I paid
for which was three it was 3.75. okay
so you don't have much in the house as
far as Equity I I don't what are you
renting it for it's kind of worm Thirty
One Hundred okay
yeah I'm I mean you asked for our
opinion I'll give it to you if you were
married and you guys had a mortgage and
you said hey let's get another house and
another mortgage and put very little
down I would say don't do that Carrie
and so that tells me we're gonna sell
the house and uh any of the profits we
can throw at his mortgage and we just be
about the business of getting rid of our
now one mortgage and later on down the
road you can get back into the real
estate investing game and do it with
cash and do it with a lot of peace and a
lot of wisdom so that's what I would do
if I was in your shoes
okay I like that uh idea it's a little
scary to think that I just purchased the
house and now I'm going to sell it so
that is the bummer that is because
there's going to be you know you're
paying the fees
um you may not get out of it with a
whole lot of profit
and that's okay Carrie but honestly it's
gonna be worth it like of not owning a
home you're going to be dealing with a
renter and if again if you want to get
into the real estate game it's not a bad
thing but you know a lot of people look
at this as like oh it's just such easy
passive income and it's not I mean it
ends up being kind of a part-time job
when you're a landlord and a tenant
absolutely yeah it just adds a layer to
your life that you don't need and so
yeah you may pay some extra fees and
stuff but you know what I would just
look forward and be like all right I did
it and let's move on and and I would and
I would sell it I really would because I
think you guys your first year marriage
you're gonna be able to do so much you
guys are making incredible money you're
gonna be able to knock out your your
primary mortgage and I mean you guys are
gonna start investing you're able to
have cash and travel I mean yeah there's
something for you a lot for you in the
future
you're going from two mortgages and
pretty soon you're gonna have no
mortgage and then imagine making 400k
with no payments in the world how
quickly could you stack up a whole bunch
of cash and buy property and have it if
you want it right cash flow right all
the profits yours so I love this plan
and uh can I can I gift you a little
pre-marital gift
okay I'm gonna gift you guys Financial
Peace University as our gift to you as
you embark on this journey together and
become one and watch all nine lessons
together I think it will motivate you
and inspire you give you some tools in
your tool belt a lot of knowledge uh
Rachel and I are in it if that helps any
it may not be a selling point too Carrie
I have no idea it's wonderful wonderful
I just need those every day so oh that's
so nice so fun thank you for the call
hang on the line Austin we'll get that
over to you uh and we're excited for you
guys congratulations Carrie Jeremy's up
next in San Jose Jeremy welcome to the
Ramsay show
hello what's going on
right right so
um I reached a point I had a call with
you guys a few years ago and you guys
have got me very motivated to get rid of
all my chat and uh
I did reach the point
um up until a few weeks ago where I
didn't have any debt except for my
mortgage
and
um this whole year
um I I just been
uh very impulsive with my money I'm not
sure what's going on with me and so I
bought it I bought a car and I got a
loan and my wife she found about out of
found out about it and she was very
upset that I got a loan on a car
um my you know I was kind of justifying
it by saying well you know I typically
save around 2 000 a month right after
all my expenses so I could just pay it
off right or you know I had I have a few
grand in cash I'll just start paying it
all off it and then I have a bonus
coming up in the next uh few months and
I can just pay it off all then but I I
now that I have the car I just thinking
to myself like why did I do this why am
I spending money why am I not saving my
money and why am I like I feel like I
went behind my wife's back and I got a
car because we agreed not to get loans
on stuff like this and she's upset about
it and then she told me you know because
you did this you need to go and deplete
our emergency fund and pay this car off
tomorrow
um I haven't done that yet so my
question to you guys is one I mean
typically I know you guys may encounter
people with who just seem to make their
own decisions with money
um I don't want to continue to do this
you know and secondly I mean is that the
right move to just do what my wife said
and say you know what I made a mistake
or just paid let's just take the cash
out the emergency fund and pay for the
car
well Jeremy I I appreciate I feel like
where you're at if I'm listening to your
tone correctly
um you're regretting it you're not being
prideful and spiteful and saying you
know Screw everyone else I'm gonna just
do what Jeremy wants to do I mean you
feel a level of remorse is what it
sounds like
um
so how much how much is the car how much
is the loan
well I mean the loan is the loan well
the car was like 15 but with the fees I
think it comes around it comes to 17
something okay yeah I don't know the
exact number off my head yep and if you
sold it tomorrow what could you sell it
for
because I've actually lost value uh so I
think I could sell it for probably 16 or
15. yeah yep that's what I do Jeremy I'm
selling it yeah and I would just chalk
it up we call it stupid tax around here
I was just being stupid why did I do
that we've all done it different dollar
amounts different purchases we've all
done it so if I were you I and I think
that's an act to your wife too to say
hey I screwed up and I'm going back and
I'm making this right instead of
depleting the emergency fund for a
stupid car it's not an emergency no and
then what happens when a real emergency
hits and you have no money then your
wife's really mad so uh you know this
was Financial infidelity and you have to
rebuild trust and I think a way you can
do that is by reversing this decision
selling it to show her how serious you
are but don't beat yourself up you're
not dumb we all make dumb decisions this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I am
George Campbell Ramsey personality
co-host of smart money happy hour as
well as the Ramsay show and I'm joined
by the other side of smart money happy
hour Rachel Cruz and we are taking your
calls today and if you want to check out
smart money happy hour you can do that
on the Ramsay Network wherever you
listen to podcasts it's also on YouTube
just the audio portion but I'm excited
to announce that in 2023 we're coming to
you with video
people have been asking they want to see
it they want to believe it and so an
episode just released yesterday all
about love is blinds best and most
cringe-worthy money lessons and it's one
of Rachel's favorite reality shows I
love love is fun so this was really just
a gift for Rachel to talk about her
favorite reality show at work I know I
don't want to do Laguna Beach next I
binge that we got we got a lot of good
Pup Culture on this on this podcast so
make sure make sure to check it out and
some good lessons George you're right
it's a real time life happening there's
a lot of what not to do and On These
reality shows and a few that are like
okay thumbs up you're doing great oh boy
good I know Dave Dave was talking about
how he listens to every episode he's
like I mean it's all so good I didn't
really like the last episode The Love is
Blind one I was like oh not not the
target demo don't yeah yeah I thought
you're gonna say Dave watch his love is
blind I was like that is the shocking
revelation of the year that could be a
reality show right there oh boy well
we're going back to the phones this hour
the number to call is triple eight eight
two five five two two five you jump in
we'll talk about your life and your
money Eric has chosen to do that and
he's over in Saint Paul Minnesota Eric
welcome to the show
hey guys thanks for taking my call
absolutely what's going on with you
um so I guess my question today is I in
in a three-year long relationship I'm 19
and my girlfriend's 18
um and she's not really familiar with
the plan but she's planning on going to
college soon
and I'm just
I can see a future with her and I'm
scared I don't want her to go into debt
but every time I guess we we were raised
differently and I grew up in a
um less fortunate circumstance and but
she's been able to spend more and so
there's kind of a disconnect there and I
don't know if it's any of my business
um being that we're still dating now
we're still so young or what I can do
well you're very wise for your age for
even considering all of this in the
equation is she going to college near
you are you guys going to get split up
uh no she's going near us no good our
hometown okay that bodes well yeah I
mean do you see yourself
proposing anytime soon you think you
guys are gonna get married you know in
in like the next year or do you think oh
no no we're still too young we're gonna
wait it out a few years wait till she
graduates like what what is your plan
Eric with her
um well we both knocked up some college
credits I'm about graduated with a
bachelor's and then she's kind of on a
similar path
um wow so this is like an accelerated
program
yeah after a high school and several
classes as well well what I'm kind of
getting at Eric is depending upon
um how quickly you're going to make a
decision when it comes to something like
marriage will be the speed at which I
would have a conversation with her so
I'm not gonna knock your age I was young
when I got married I was 21 so I was
just two years older than you I got
married young
um so you know if you guys really are
going down this path and and it starts
to get more serious and you're like okay
yeah marriage is a for real thing we
kind of have a timeline we're mapping
this out then that's when the values
conversation comes into play is hey is
Dick going to be a part of our life or
are we going to live debt free what does
it look like uh to live on a budget
together what does it look like you know
maybe if she's a spender and you're the
saver which is my marriage I'm the
spender he's the saver uh you know and
you start to have those kind of values
conversations you guys are still going
to be different
um you know you kind of your god-given
personality but uh you start to have
those conversations say hey how are we
going to work together as a team but I
wouldn't feel the pressure to do that
Eric again if marriage isn't really in
close in proximity because while yes she
could be the one and you know that at 19
and you guys could get married and all
of that also a lot of Life happens
um you know in your in your late teens
and early 20s especially when you're
making decisions like college or moving
for a job you just never know what's
going to happen so I would accelerate
the conversation as the wedding
conversation starts to accelerate and
become more of a reality but yeah that
would be my opinion yeah have you had
conversations with her about money so
far that have not gone well what kind of
makes you think she's super far off
um I guess I don't know I've always been
like a really heavy spender so
um I don't know I I feel bad I I think
maybe sometimes I
say things I shouldn't when we're
shopping
um but I also do it because I what are
you saying give me give me an example
like she'll uh like a pair of shoes that
I don't think she'll wear I'll say like
um do you think you'll actually wear
this or do you think you'll actually
need this and it's a little passive
aggressive that sounds like I have for
sure said that
um so that doesn't end well for me yeah
well I mean it never ends well for me
Eric too in my marriage and Eric you
never want to get in the position where
you feel like you're the you're
parenting her or something and she's 18
and if she's never really done stuff on
her own she may not know
um so yeah I think that there's a lot of
Grace here
um I think that there is a level of
reality of your age you know she's 18
she she may not know and you know she's
lived one way and again with a lot of
Grace and a lot of humility on your end
Eric uh to start those conversations I
think would be great yeah the I mean I
was a knucklehead at your age when it
came to money so I don't want someone
judging me for the rest of my life based
on what I did how I was at 18. yeah and
so I would definitely have some Grace I
feel like you're almost you're you're so
mature for your age as far as the way
you're thinking and so I think we also
need to go chill out we're not adults
yet we don't have bills to pay so I
don't need to be like what are your
thoughts on annuities versus 401ks you
know you can just have more General
money conversations with her and say hey
what's your plan for for school are you
are you applying for scholarships like
how cool would it be if we could both
graduate debt free and all of our income
from our job stayed with us and you can
just start to kind of see how she feels
about those kinds of things
I guess another part of the problem is
that um I was fortunate enough to have
my college paid for through like grants
and stuff through the state
um and so
like you haven't even
you haven't even tried to go through
college
um
without
taking out life she's going away you
don't get to talk to me about that
because you're over here and you got all
this this free money to go to college
have you helped her maybe apply for some
scholarships
helped her find something you know I
mean I encouraged her to look but I yeah
no I think you kind of come alongside
her not as a condescending coach but
more as a a friend a boyfriend and go
hey I want to see you win I care about
you as a person and I know you got a lot
on your play right now I'd love to help
in any way I can yeah and I would leave
the boundary at that Eric because as
much as you love her you guys are just
dating it's not your wife if you were in
a marriage this would be a different
kind of conversation you're just dating
and so
um you don't she she doesn't have
responsibility to you I mean she doesn't
so
um I don't know there's that that
tension that lies there but I think
having those conversations I think is
totally fine
um yeah to bring it up and just casually
be like all right let's let's talk about
college let's talk about and again as
the future starts to become more of a
reality it's like all right let's talk
about this this is really important to
me this is a value system play to me
um and have those but I would I would
just kind of I I would take a breath
Eric just
I would just chill and these are her
decisions you're not married to her so
obviously you want her to go one path
but even if she doesn't we tell people
you can marry someone with debt you know
like you're like that is still a thing
again you want your values to align uh
but if she makes this you know if she
decides to go in student loan debt at 18
you know it's not wise but she gets to
make that decision her and her family
and she's gonna go along and and then
you guys if you guys end up getting
married then yeah that'll be a
discussion but yeah I don't know I just
I want you to enjoy some of this life
too you know what I mean I don't want
you to get skip straight to adulthood
well just just like uh the Attention
Point well you could watch uh borrowed
future with her it's free on YouTube and
that can start a conversation without
you starting it for her and just her
saying hey that was a really interesting
documentary what are you what are your
thoughts on that and it's a good way to
kind of get those values out without
making it weird sure so I'm rooting you
on man I hope this thing works out you
sound awesome Eric keep up the good work
on your end for sure you're killing it
that puts this hour of the Ramsay show
in the book books my thanks to my
co-host Rachel Cruz all of our listeners
out there and all the folks in the booth
keeping the show afloat we've got Austin
and will and James and Zach and Andrew
and Josh a whole bunch of folks we'll be
back with you before you know it this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
do you love a good day Brandt want to
see the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your mind I'm Ramsay personality George
Campbell joined by best-selling author
and host of The Rachel crew show you
guessed it it's Rachel Cruz herself and
we are taking your calls at triple eight
eight two five five two two five you
jump in we'll talk about whatever is
going on in your life budgeting paying
off debt paying off the house investing
Building Wealth avoiding the traps
saving up that emergency fund we are
here for you America and Pearson is
kicking us off this hour in Sioux Falls
South Dakota Pearson welcome to the show
hey how's it going going great how can
we help today
hey uh so I'm 24 years old I'm currently
living with my parents I've been saving
up money for a house for about five
years now uh just one day and one am I
ready to buy a house
um and two
if I am um should I wait till the market
cools down or just go right away that
those are my questions
awesome so you've been saving for five
years how much do you have saved
I've got about 60 000 in cash way to go
I got retirement so I've got about 40
000 in retirement
you're crushing it what do you do for
work
column HVAC commercial Easter egg very
good do you have any debt
zero day awesome and is that 60 000
include your emergency fund or do you
have money outside of that
um it includes emergency funds okay so
most of that can go towards this down
payment for the house and you're
wondering am I ready to do it am I ready
to move out have you looked at homes in
that area are you wanting to stay in
Sioux Falls
yes
um I mean prices are pretty outrageous
right now
um give me a number of like a single
family or a condo an apartment what are
we talking
what am I looking to pay for
yeah are you wanting a single family
home yeah single family home okay I'm
looking to spend about 250 if I can but
I mean anything
like worth living in is above 300 right
now so I'm wondering do I need to raise
my price or should I wait you know
yeah how much you make a year
so for the last five years I've been
making about 46 to 50. okay and I just
bumped up to making 110 whoa doing what
the same thing
same exact thing uh I was just kind of
just getting my foot in the door at
first and I switched to a different job
and wow
different company
yes it's a different company um I I
commute to Minneapolis
um for the week but it's all paid for
and
so but that's where the money is so I'm
I'm willing to you know yeah good for
you how long have you been in that job
uh just three months now okay that's
awesome but what I was going to say is
with that income I mean yeah more than
doubled which is awesome so
um I mean yeah looking at looking at
your numbers I mean I mean you'd have
50k to put down for a for a down payment
which is that good 20 down for for a 250
000 house but that does leave you 10
grand for as an emergency fund so
um I mean and making sure yeah your that
everything's no more your mortgage is no
more than
um 25 of your take-home pay once you do
your budget and everything but I mean
the the numbers you're giving us Pearson
I mean they they look great if you want
to save some more for that emergency
fund have a little bit more than that
ten thousand you could do that just have
some buffer uh and making sure that it's
yeah more around that six month mark
because
um
yeah you there's no urgency to buy this
house so I would I would have a really
great emergency fund and then I mean I
think you're definitely to the point
about you know moving out are you
wanting to stay
in the Sioux Falls Area do you think or
are you going to want to okay I want to
stay around where the west side of Sioux
Falls
um so that 110 that's just kind of what
I'm on Pace to make right now it's it
just
that's getting 60 hours I mean 20 hours
of overtime as well so I don't know what
should I okay I calculate it as just 40
hours and just anything over time
there's extra or if it's not sustainable
and you don't see yourself doing this
you know extra overtime forever I would
calculate it based on that number minus
the overtime to give you a more
realistic number so that you don't have
shell shock when you get into this house
but one thing you might consider since
you have this income right now is hey
what if over the next six months since
I'm living with my parents I have no
bills I'm just stacking up cash could I
take that 60 000 up to a hundred
thousand in the next six months and now
I can get that 300 000 home still have
over 20 down and uh you know we say that
we want you to get a 15-year fixed rate
mortgage where the payments no more than
a quarter of your take-home pay so that
helps you figure out how much house I
can afford today yeah and I would say to
Pearson because of you know you're
single right I didn't hear you say WiFi
yeah you may not need that but you know
what I mean depending on what you you
know just because you qualify for a
certain level of mortgage or even
whatever the bank's always happy to give
you more yes yes and even our formula if
you look and say okay yeah but I don't
need that I'm great with just starting
with a condo and living here for a few
years maybe upgrading later so so really
too you know it's it's what you need in
the moment what you can afford what's
wise I mean all of that comes into play
and and yeah I have a timeline and the
idea of living at home is great because
you're saving that money so that's the
pro but there is something to Pearson
about about being on your own like there
is just this I don't know this growing
up that ends up happening when you're
the one that comes home and has to look
in the refrigerator and say oh man we're
out of milk I'm out of milk I need to go
to the grocery store yeah and paying
bills I mean there's just this level of
growing up
um of dignity that's placed in you that
that is different so I mean again you
could go rent for a year somewhere if
you wanted to you have enough money here
though I just feel like you know buying
a home is is totally good you know again
if these numbers all work out but yeah
you've done the hard work I mean you've
gone out of debt if you had any to begin
with you've got a bunch of money in the
bank you're a very wise mature 24 year
old
oh it's all my my dad has been watching
Dave Ramsey and I've been watching it
growing up and I got to give all the
credit to him that's nice well you did
it too man so you're saying that hundred
thousand dollar marks I'll be able to
get that 300 000 house in well again it
all depends go you can use the mortgage
calculator at ramseysolutions.com it's
free and you can type your numbers in
and say hey if I got a 300 000 house I
put a hundred thousand down what kind of
payment would that be if on that 15-year
fix and if that's about a quarter of
your take-home pay so you're after tax
but before any other deductions like
investing in retirement and minus your
overtime and minus the budget around
just that 40 hour a week so if you're
bringing home four grand a month the
payment comes out to a thousand you're
like all right great that's The Sweet
Spot I'm ready to do this or you say all
right I'm gonna compromise I'm gonna get
a condo for now because I can get one
for 200 Grand and that's really going to
set me up for success and I can always
upgrade to the single family later on
down the road when I'm married and need
you know five bedrooms yeah so if you're
doing this with a lot of wisdom man
great job Pearson you're doing great
this is inspiring Rachel can we just
have more piercings in the world
who are willing to do the hard work yes
and amen he's not trying to shortcut
this thing go hey I got a huge pile of
debt but I want to be a homeowner and
it's that perseverance and this this
guy's saved up 60 grand for a down
payment on a home and has no other debt
and I'm like it's it's that's the
perseverance that's the longevity of the
attitude and Spirits yes that you end up
winning financially and Building Wealth
and keeping it because it's not this
flash in the pan I got a shortcut I mean
he he's doing it the right way and he's
working in the trades and I've got mad
respect for all of the trades and you
probably don't have fancy four-year
degrees with hundreds of thousands of
dollars in debt to show for it this is
the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more verse
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George Campbell Join This Hour by Rachel
Cruz and the phone lines are open and
they are waiting for you America so call
us up at triple eight eight two five
five two two five well this hour we've
got a special segment coming up at 2 30
central time that's 3 30 Eastern and
it's a new segment we've been trying
called 10 and 10 and this is where we go
live on Instagram while live on the
Ramsey Show when we take Instagram
viewer questions from the chat and we
try to answer 10 questions in under 10
minutes and Rachel you are you're new to
this Ken and I have been doing this on
the air are you nervous uh no I feel
like there's a challenge can't wait you
gotta answer quick though like we don't
get to just chat it up it's quick yeah
lightning round response I'm great at
that I'm I'm gonna Ace this you'll do
way better than Ken no you and Ken are
both very great off the cuff so I have
no now deloney I would be worried about
because he can tend to be longer winded
we don't it comes to his responses and
we don't know what's going to come out
of it we don't know what's going to
happen so yeah I'm the safe bet George
we're to win a contest right now of 10
money questions to be answered in 10
minutes I think I'm I think I'm your gal
well the only thing you win is the
hearts of America that is the grand
prize and I hope you get it today so
here's the deal you got to tune in to
Rachel's Instagram at 2 30 central time
she's going live at Rachel Cruz on
Instagram and uh we will be taking
questions from the chat not from the
phone lines just for that one segment at
2 30 Central Time coming up so don't
miss that but for now let's go to the
trusty phone lines Amy joins us in Tampa
Florida Amy welcome to the Ramsay show
thank you thanks for taking my call sure
how can we help
um okay well my parents are 75 and 77
and they live in Kansas City
um also my sister
she's uh she lives there with her 10
year old daughter my sister is disabled
and has a lot of health problems
so
there's several things going on but one
is that my dad has this coin collection
and I think he's running them into a lot
of debt collecting the coins and my
sister has a credit card she just uses
you know for whatever fast food whatever
and my mom keeps getting scammed I don't
know what to do I don't know what to do
if to help them I mean and the house is
overflowing with stuff
it sounds like the average Americans
uh so what are they hoarders like for
real it's a it's a what are they buying
um
I mean I think there's kind of are
hoarders I mean it's not like the
episodes of Hoarders where the house is
filthy and stuff there's just stuff
everywhere it's like so Amy and toys and
so Amy your heart for your family is so
great right you never you don't want to
see people you love making bad decisions
you don't want to see people you love in
pain you don't want to see them you know
in situations but first and foremost you
have to know it's not your
responsibility
I know okay
I want that burden off of you even
though your heart longs for something at
the end of the day they are all adults
and it is not your responsibility now
can you have a conversation with them
sure and I think there's ways that you
can do it better than other ways we can
kind of talk about that but
um but at the end of the day you have to
it took me it took me a lot of therapy
sessions just to realize you don't you
can't control people you can't and as
much as you want something the outcome
is not dependent upon you it is it is on
them and so there is a level of this
that you have to like as I hear the
concern and I hear the stress in your
voice and so
um while you don't want to see people
you love in pain
there is a level that you you do have to
let go of that control because you can't
control them
well last Christmas when I went home
they had
schemes and they have allowed these
people to charge 8 500 to their credit
card yeah so luckily I just happened to
be there at the right time that we were
we disputed it and the credit card
company gave them their money back but
um it messed up their credit score and
I'm afraid they're going to be doing the
same thing again because my mom said oh
somebody sent us a letter and they're
going to help us get out of debt and I
talked to the gal the other day and
she's going to call me back tomorrow and
I'm like oh no not again what do you say
in that do you do you say hey Mom do you
remember what happened last time
and like ask her questions and and let
her come to a level of
an epiphany
um I mean
we've talked about it throughout the
year she
I don't know if she forgets or or what I
mean I think they're so desperate with
the debt just they want that quick easy
answer sure sure
I I don't I don't know I don't I don't
know if I need to step in and try to
take over the finances I hate to do that
my mom
probably not and my dad handled I mean
my mom my mom handles all all of the you
know bill paying and all that my dad
doesn't even know how cute he never has
so it's kind of all on my mom yeah and I
think the next conversation with mom is
Mom I don't want you guys getting taken
advantage of and there's a lot of scams
going around especially with folks that
are older and none of them are real and
so here's what I want you to do don't
answer the phone from people you don't
know never give them money never give
them access to your account never give
them your credit card number and if
something does come up let me know and I
can help figure it out and that way
there's no condescension it's just you
coming around them to help them from
getting taken advantage of would that be
a different conversation
um I've had that conversation with them
except for the you know let me know and
I'll help you figure it out part right
okay because yeah because I think that
you're I think that you're a great
resource for them you know I mean when I
was saying letting go of control just
knowing that you can control them but
also you're in a position that you're
like okay
um have you been following our plan do
you you know are you are you familiar
with with the Ramsay yeah okay so what
you could say too is hey Mom and Dad
this has really helped me a lot and
almost using a third party Us by the way
me and George can be your beer bad cops
and say yeah there's like this great
podcast that I love
um we can even if you hold on the line
Amy Austin will pick up and we will gift
to them Financial Peace universities so
that they can go together through it and
you can give them that as a gift from us
and just say hey be awesome Mom and Dad
I think you guys should watch these
videos uh I'm here to help I would love
to help help you guys set up your first
budget because with that every dollar
plus will be there the our budgeting app
and you can kind of be the one that says
you can't push it you know like you
can't force it but that you're so
available to help because you are
concerns and sometimes again the third
party us being the ones explaining
things and talking about things and all
that sometimes parents or for anyone
it's easy it's an easier pill to swallow
than their daughter preaching at them
right if that makes sense so so if that
helps as well
um I think that's a great idea
okay I I will try that just take it one
day at a time so you what
I'm going up at Christmas okay yes so I
think I think if I mean if I were in
your shoes and I don't know the exact
relationship you have with them but but
enough of like yeah if my parents were
involved in stuff that I'm like gosh
that is just not wise I mean I would I
have such a big mouth so I I would have
to probably say something and just but
but out of the heart of like here's what
I'm seeing and again it may not be any
of my business but it this is what I'm
picking up and I feel like you guys are
stressed and I just if I can be a
resource to help guide any of this I
really want to be here because it's
helped me in my life you know and you
kind of tell your story of where you're
at with money and um that's the best
testimony right there and for your
sister who's using the credit card along
with whatever gift you're getting or you
can gift her The Total Money Makeover
and say hey
um this book really helped me the
principals in here have allowed me to
just have like a freedom with money and
I know life's tough for you with the
disabled 10 year old like that's a
really stressful place to be so not
having to stress about money I think
could be a huge help and I hope you'll
read this and got what I got out of it
we'll throw that in too Amy so also
throwing a T-Mobile notebook too for
your sister yep Merry Christmas thank
you yes thank you so much for the call
Amy wishing you the best what a what a
giant heart Amy I know I mean it's so
hard it's so hard I can't control people
I can't change people I wish I had the
magic wand now all you can do is be a
resource for them and live your life in
such a way they go wow Rachel seemed
just happy and stress-free what is she
doing with her life oh good stuff this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show if
you've been listening uh for a little
bit now you know that we are going live
with a very exciting segment called 10
and 10 where we go live on Instagram
while on the Ramsey Show and take
questions from the Instagram chat and
currently we are live on Rachel Cruz's
Instagram so go check that out at Rachel
Cruz on Instagram jump into the live
chat with your questions here we go see
I know okay are you ready do you scroll
do I scroll it's a free-for-all it's
just happy and it all starts right now
okay let's go first question who are we
going to answer let's answer the last
one uh how many credit cards do you guys
have honestly I know
I get that sometimes and people like I
mean but really like you have at least
one it's like they really don't
understand you can live without one you
really don't
really don't amazing uh let's see what
we have here you can scroll as well
Rachel what's the best way to carry cash
oh that's interesting there's a little
uh softball pitch I'd say the Rachel
Cruz wallet that's the best way no but
really having cash it's the envelope
system so you take your budget look at
the categories that you tend to
overspend and cash those out especially
if you're new to budgeting carrying cash
it's so helpful not only do you spend
less study show but you're accountable
you know exactly how much is left in
that category in your budget and it
helps you all right uh rafa.ie said what
do you guys think about major banks
financial advisors like Chase Bank of
America and Wells Fargo it's a big fat
thumbs down for me on that one Rachel I
don't trust them because they have a
vested interest in selling you all the
products from that specific bank which
is all going to be debt products when
it's attached to a bank that's usually
what they're looking for so yeah not a
fan no thanks on that one okay oh this
is a fun one for you Rachel e Rogers
said what do I teach my four-year-old
about money oh
um I mean at 4 or
um
I would start with like
maybe one or two chores that you help
them with and say hey yeah let's and you
pay them a little something and then do
that maybe over a week and then take
them to a store buy a little something
and it probably won't be big but they
kind of slowly start to grasp that money
comes from work it just doesn't come
from Mom and Dad's back pocket and so
you can do that at four you'll help them
along the way very age-appropriate but I
love it Deanna betz says if I'm
investing over 15 should I feel guilty
about spending on myself fun no Deanna
number one only be investing 15 until
you have a paid for house but no do not
be guilty about spending especially if
it was in the budget that means you did
it with intentionality that's right
that's right on purpose Rachel you'll
love this one yes uh how should the
budget change when expecting a baby oh
okay so it yeah it will change I mean
you'll have line items in there that you
normally don't have and so there's
something that got added and until the
baby actually come comes I had like a it
was almost just like I mean stuff to get
before baby comes so yeah you want to
make sure you're stocked up on diapers
you have the clothes you're gonna do the
nursery so you want to price out a crib
you want to price out if you get a
changing table or some front expenses
yeah ongoing items and that can be
arranged you can go like really
expensive on all of this or really
inexpensive so again there's a range all
right uh Miss Kania said what do you
think about online banking I'm a big fan
of online banking we both have high
yield savings accounts that are with
online banks and uh but I also have a
brick and mortar local bank and so I
like to have both I want to make sure I
can go talk to someone in person yeah
and when I need to and it's a big value
in having like a local credit union as
well yeah our emergency fund and kind of
above savings that isn't retirement is
with an online bank Ally we use and then
we have yeah a local bank that has like
our checking and everything all right we
got some love from the Netherlands thank
you when is a live event coming to Miami
Florida I don't think we're going near
Miami anymore we need to go we should
welcome to Miami can you tell Dave Dave
if you're listening let's go to Miami
all right let's see what else we got
here have you guys ever been denied
something because you don't have a
credit card that's an interesting one
our hardest one which we've somehow
gotten around it but but a a rental car
that's the one that we kind of always
run into I feel like but for us we use I
mean I guess it's okay just yeah we we
use a company I guess we can promote
yeah sure Enterprise I mean that's when
we use we had great experiences we just
have an account so every time we yeah
every time we've gone
um to rent a car like at the beach
saying we've never had trouble we've
used that but I feel like early on we
were like having to like look around and
ask that question so rental car was the
only thing airport once can be dice here
make sure to check the policy of
wherever you're renting a car from about
their debit card policy but Enterprise
usually it's like a 200 hold yeah and it
comes back once you return the car it's
not that big of a deal uh this is a
governor from Marty should I be
contributing to a match matching 401K
while in debt no no contributions no
investing at all until we are out of
Consumer Debt and one big reason is
you're probably investing a few percent
points now you're going to be up to 15
once you're out of debt and you need
every dime you can free up to get
gazelle intents about that debt that's
right get out of debt as quickly as
possible are you watching the World Cup
I'm not I gotta be honest dude I'm not
either but I see it everywhere and I
kind of feel like
I feel like I'd be a bandwagon fan I
know 100 engineer will a big soccer fan
I'm sure he's staying tuned but USA go
America okay good all right USA USA
we're still in it okay um is there a
good strategy for paying for High
student debt it's the same strategy we
use for any kind of Consumer Debt that's
right the debt snowball list them out
smallest to largest regardless of the
interest rate attack the smaller one
with a Vengeance with all the margin you
can muster up while making minimum
payments on the rest and then you keep
rolling that snowball as you free up the
payments that's right well done simple
uh how long should you save in baby step
3B oh this is a hot debate it's not a
time I mean for me I'm like it's not a
major time limit it's more the amount I
have to to buy a house but I know people
want to start investing so you can
actually split it up we do say that
sometimes it's like yeah if you want to
go 50 50 you know you're you're using
some money to start investing if it's
going to be a long time while saving up
for the down payment just takes you
longer for the down payment but yeah
that's a good one is it okay to have a
credit card with a low limit
oh no hello boo just use your debit card
I don't understand the obsession with
using other people's money because they
feel everyone feels like you get your
rewards yeah you fit and stuff but
here's the deal how are you getting
stuff well the bank's giving it to you
because other people
are paying fees and interest so you're
actually getting the free stuff because
other people are not handling their
money well and are struggling and so
it's a growth system just pay cash you
guys it's not worth it I saw I think it
was Jade our newest Ramsay personalities
she said
um you could oh gosh what was the quote
oh man I don't want to butcher it but it
was like you can be mathematically
correct when with also
um
it's really good because it's like yeah
does that all make sense mathematic like
sure but that doesn't make that doesn't
mean that you have peace that's a good
way it's something like that all right
this is a fun one for you Rachel uh
someone just started watching instead of
listening and they're asking Rachel are
you left-handed oh yeah I am wow are you
left-handed no doesn't that mean you're
smarter or something isn't there a thing
you're supposed to be more creative but
that is I think Rachel just shut that
argument down uh let's see here uh
Rachel where can I get a signed book how
do people get a signed book we do them
at a Live Events who is it
Butler DM me and I'll look for your DM
and send me your address I'll send you
one you're about to get a thousand DMS
no just for him it's okay
okay does the mortgage count as debt yes
mortgage does count as debt but it
doesn't count as Consumer Debt in baby
step two and so save that for what we
call baby step six once you're out of
debt you have the emergency fund you're
investing 15 saving some for kids
college then start attacking that
mortgage but it is absolutely debt try
not paying and see what happens well
actually don't try that because they
will take away your home not a fun
experiment not a fun experiment all
right oh budgeting for private school
what are your thoughts on that Rachel
yeah Minnesota mom life yeah if it's in
your budget and you're able to afford it
then then yeah and I know some people
they they sacrifice you know part of
their lifestyle in order to send their
kids to private school depending on
where they live we live in a great area
so our kids go to public but I know
people have thoughts about that and some
people don't live in great areas where
the public schools are not great and you
want your kids to have a better
education than what that can provide so
that's all if values conversation but
you want to have the money for it you
don't want to stress your family out all
right I think we have time for one last
one Stephanie do you recommend and iul
that is indexed universal life insurance
no it is a scam meant to make the
insurance sales people money stay away
from that stick to term life insurance
only James how many questions did we hit
I lost count after 15 so you all blow
that's a record Rachel that is a record
way to go thank you all for tuning in to
Rachel's Instagram live with your
questions in the chat we'll be back to
the phones in the next segment so give
us a call at triple eight eight two five
five two two five way to go Rachel great
job George this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
folks the Cyber Monday sale that we've
had ends this weekend and this is your
chance to give some meaningful gifts
this Christmas without spending money
that you don't have so go to
ramseysolutions.com and Shop our
best-selling books and tools for under
10 bucks you can still find some great
deals on Christmas gifts for everyone on
your list and have them delivered in
time here's some of my favorites we've
got some quick read books like Dave's
new one the momentum theorem Dr John
deloney's redefining anxiety all for
under 10 bucks and of course the new
2023 Ramsay gold planner with Rachel
Cruz myself Dr John deloney and Rachel
Cruz's new wallet in red great color
there for the amazing women in your life
I'm going to get one for my mom
hopefully she's not listening and for
the guys we've got some for you too we
have some new Ramsay apparel uh you
might have seen me rock some here on the
show t-shirts crewnecks hoodies with
some of your favorite Ramsay sayings on
them I've been waiting a long time for
the Ramsay swag and I'm hoping for a
better than I deserve sweatshirt Rachel
in case you're trying to shop for me oh
man I got you George she's writing it
down folks and for all your family
friends co-workers we have questions for
humans conversation cards that are super
fun hilarious they'll spark some great
convos and select decks are on sale for
only 10 bucks so guys are you living and
giving generously this season these
deals are a great way for you to pass on
what you've learned from our books and
tools to others who might be struggling
with money relationships or career and
it could give them the same hope that
changed your life so go check out our
Cyber Monday sale before it ends at
ramsesolutions.com
let's go to the phones this hour I'm
George Campbell joined by Rachel Cruz
and we're about to be joined by our new
friend Robert in Atlanta Georgia Robert
welcome to the show
hey thank you what's going on with you
well I'm I'm turning 59 soon and my wife
and I have you know realized that
retirement age is coming up very quickly
and how poorly is it we think we planned
for it
uh
I rediscovered the Ramsey Show here in
Atlanta just recently and you know
started doing our own calculations of
how we are in the steps and
we're kind of our order is kind of mixed
up and I'm trying to figure out now
okay to get me to where I want to be and
retire and
a few years
how should I do that
yeah it's a great question Robert so
um how much debt do you guys have
uh we have
three not three thousand on a car which
we're about to pay off and then about a
15 000 on just a personal loan okay
and then 200 000 mortgage okay
and then the mortgage and then how much
do you guys have saved in retirement
uh I have
140 000 in a 401k
and my wife we've only been married for
about two and a half years so she has
about 370 and one is it a 403 b I think
it's called and then another
retirement account I think it's about 90
000. okay
um what kind of cash do you guys have on
hand
we have about twenty thousand dollars
twenty thousand a little more and then
no other Investments it's not retirement
or anything else
well I have a pension that'll you know
start when I'm retired it'd be you know
three thousand a month if
you know I drew the whole thing but you
know she'll probably outlive me so I'm
sure you know we'll stretch it out so
she'll get it in every smaller amount
okay what's your current household
income
uh 240. oh that's great news
yeah well this bodes well if we can hang
on to that income for a few more years
yeah yeah that's couldn't be a problem
well the good news Robert is you have
the cash in the bank to just be Consumer
Debt free today
pay off the car loan pay off the
personal loan does that scare you to
have only 3 000 in the bank
uh it would probably shock my wife yeah
what else would shocker is not having
payments next month and how quickly you
guys are going to rebuild that savings
making 240 with no Consumer Debt I mean
how long would that take
a few months at Max
yeah well we're still paying for one one
kid through college so that's the other
you know she's we got his rent and all
that I forgot to mention that sure but
even with the car loan payment and the
personal loan payment freed up on top of
the margin you guys have with that 240
income you should be able to save up
twenty thousand dollars
um you know that's another 17. so you'll
be down to three if you pay it off your
debt today and you could save up 17 in
the next few months
yeah okay and now we're on track to uh
continue investing in retirement 15 of
your incomes and then start paying off
the mortgage that's that's my other
question because you know we're both you
know uh investing the max you know what
is that 52 000 a year into our 401ks
should I cut that back to just 15
percent and
pay the rest towards the mortgage or
continue you know putting in the max
no I would I would pull it back
um to that 15 yes and and throw the rest
at the mortgage but I would also you
know run out the numbers
um you know that may mean Robert working
maybe another year two three years
because once you have no mortgage
payment and a paid for house then you
guys have really freed up your income to
throw a lot more towards
um retirement and then other investing
if you want to do that as well if you've
already maxed out your roths do you guys
have any Roth IRAs open
yeah yes I I do I've put
six percent of the 401K
and then 17 into the Roth
which I need to bump up a little bit
probably
okay so let me give you a vision of what
this could look like if you follow the
advice that we're laying out here today
you could be Consumer Debt free with
three thousand dollars in the bank left
over we're gonna rebuild to a three to
six months emergency fund let's call
that twenty thousand dollars you do that
in a few months now you're making 240k
and all you have left is a 200 000
mortgage what if you could pay that off
in a few years maybe throw 75 100 at it
each year with that great income well
now two years from now three years from
now you have no payments in the world
and now you can really start stacking up
for retirement
do you see how that kind of creates a
domino effect create some momentum
yeah and so that's what I think your
best plan is to retire with dignity
going into retirement with no payments
in the world and a giant pile of cash
and this money is going to continue to
grow for you in retirement
so you're on track you're closer than
you think
nice that doesn't seem that way I mean I
have hope just looking at these numbers
because of your income now if you
weren't making much and it was going to
take you a long time to pay off this
debt it would be a different situation
but if you can continue making this 240
you're going to be done cash flow in
college pretty soon the mortgage is
going to be done in a few years that
really frees up your income and Robert
and I would really encourage you and
your wife to to get on a budget and to
do that month to month because there may
be part of this too that you guys have
kind of just been living and you're like
I mean you kind of know where your
money's going kind of not you're just
enjoying it and now that you're sucked
into this plan to go really hardcore and
to be budgeting and knowing exactly what
you're spending uh on each category and
you know what's going on that in and of
itself is going to actually probably get
you some more money you're going to feel
like you've got to raise is what a lot
of people say when they first start
budgeting because you didn't realize how
much you guys were just spending and so
that Focus knowledge as well I think is
going to help your fear because when and
George said you're doing great and
Robert's like doesn't feel like it it's
because a lot of stuff of that is in
your head robber like there's a lot of
things going on you have a lot of
thoughts and it's like your numbers are
up here but when you start getting facts
on paper it's amazing what happens and
by doing that that's that's the budget
and I think that's really going to help
you guys have a game plan month to month
you're going to start feeling in control
of your money and then you're going to
be able to actually see the margin to
throw at not just this Consumer Debt but
even your house yeah and if you're not
already working with a great financial
advisor we have them at
ramseysolutions.com click on Ramsay
recommends get in touch with a
smartvester pro it's not just about
where to invest it's someone to give you
a holistic strategy for your money for
your retirement to talk you off the
ledge of bad decisions to help you
understand this stuff and so I would
highly recommend getting one of those in
your corner as well but anyone who's
older it is not too late for you to
retire with dignity no matter what has
happened in your past you can make
progress you can do this stuff but it's
going to take some hard work some
sacrifice some diligence that that puts
this hour of the Ramsay show in the
books I'm George Campbell she's Rachel
Cruz this has been the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
it's the Ramsay show where America hangs
out to have a conversation about your
life and your money I'm George Campbell
Join This Hour by Rachel Cruz we are
your co-hosts this hour also co-hosts of
another Ramsay Network show called smart
money happy hour and we are happy to
take your calls this hour at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
so Rachel we get sent a lot of videos on
Instagram people always want to know our
thoughts on things our hot takes and
usually there it's things that I'm like
oh gosh I have to you know it's just
like terrible Financial advice but
sometimes there's videos that make me
smile and I go get a little a little
glimmer of hope I agree with that for
Humanity and uh this one is from a celeb
oh celeb didn't send me the video the
videos of a celebrity and I know you're
basically BFFs with Matthew McConaughey
Matthew I did have him on my show he was
on your show you're a big fan of his
book green lights and uh this clip has
popped up and it has to do with money
and so I thought I'd play it for you and
get your reaction to it and talk about
it I can't wait you ready yes let's see
what he has to say
like money doesn't make you happy but it
makes me very happy I mean I like money
uh
uh take money's money's good and that if
you have some it can take away a lot of
stress that a lot of people have that
don't yeah I mean I'm happy to say that
I
my rent's going to be paid
my kids are going to eat not everyone
can say that
um
after that you know
if you look at certain things you need
you look at certain things that are
luxuries
um I wouldn't say it buys you happiness
though can buy you access to things you
may want and then like anybody you know
so keep an eye on those things you want
because that more options don't always
make you happier that's good dang
Matthew the way he says everything is
just so cool oh it's just I could listen
to this voice he could have just said
the ABCs and I would have been like that
was brilliant well that's so smart
but the the content was a great point
it's a great point because there's one
side of the coin that everyone's like
money doesn't make you happy it's not
important and as Zig Ziglar which this
next Generation has no questions
but uh but his quote which I think is
just so funny is like money is not
everything but it's right up there with
oxygen so like
there is a level where like yeah it
doesn't necessarily bring you Joy but it
brings you a level of Peace because you
don't have stress about where your next
meal is coming from are you going to
have shelter even to the point that if
you know a family member gets sick and
you have money in the bank to go buy a
plane ticket to go see them like you
know all of those things it gives you
the ability to live your life so yeah on
one side people are like no it doesn't
make you happy and I'm like well no but
it does like he said give you access but
on the other end if that's the only
thing you live for is the number in your
checking account you are going to live a
pretty empty life yes I think chasing
happiness through stuff is never going
to end well because we know that money
and happiness there's not always a
correlation there's folks in third world
countries who have way more joy than
most Americans do that's right and they
don't have a lot of stuff but they still
have joy which is the end result I would
hope of Happiness which is longer
lasting it's not this fleeting thing of
like we went on a vacation and it made
us it made us happy and then we came
back home and we were still miserable
right because you go with you and when
you have debt in your life you know
Studies have shown you're not sleeping
as well it has a physical weight on your
body and so I think that's that's kind
of what's holding people back is if
you're broke and in debt it's going to
be harder to be happy yep that's the
correlation yes there's going to be more
stress more anxiety naturally versus yes
if you have if you're debt free and have
an emergency fund you have money in the
bank that money is not correlating to oh
I have that dollar amount so I'm
automatically have a better life it's I
have the ability to use it as a tool to
better my life if or when I need it yes
and our research team we've done this
state of personal finance study now for
almost two years and this is over a
thousand people so it's statistically
significant we use a third party to do
this and here's some things that we
found over a hundred million Americans
now say they're struggling or in crisis
with their finances so that's about one
out of three people yep fifty percent of
Americans say finances have had a
negative impact on their like fiances
that's interesting and because of stress
brought on by money 41 of Americans
report crying oh my goodness at least
once in the last three months that's a
lot of stress that's a literally a sad
stat that breaks my heart to hear that
and lastly 41 have experienced a panic
attack because of money at some point in
their life yep so it has an effect on
you and that's what's crazy is again
it's not just the financial effect
it's everything else it's the emotional
the mental the spiritual I mean there's
there's so much that money affects in
our lives so it's not just numbers and
that's the one thing about math or about
money that we talk about a lot on the
show it's not just about math so you can
argue interest rates and getting a loan
and using you know instead of paying it
off use that money to invest in the
market you'll make a better return it's
smarter I mean you can do math all day
long but that does not correlate to your
mental your spiritual your physical
health I mean all of that and that money
plays a role in all of that oh yeah and
a lot of people that watch these videos
Rachel they always come from like
celebrities who have a ton of money yeah
and I was like hey guys I just want to
let you know money doesn't buy you
happiness they're like easy for you to
say dude I know I know totally like I
would like to experience that yeah I
want to have a lot of money so I can say
that money is doesn't matter right and
so I understand where they're coming
from there's this angst about it of like
you don't get to tell me that kind of
thing but there's so much truth in what
Matthew McConaughey was saying and what
he really was pointing to is what we've
been teaching for 30 years which is
Financial Peace yep it's contentment
with what you have and that is what it's
all about and we teach yes build wealth
and give and that's great but the end
goal is not just that money's going to
make you happy so you should go get you
some yep the goal is get out of debt
have money in the bank so that you have
peace and margin in your life to focus
on what really matters that's right
which is your health your career your
family and yes some of the stuff that
money can buy we want you to have nice
stuff don't misunderstand it's great to
do that when you do it the right way
that's intentionality yeah and money is
just a tool it's a tool to create a life
that you love right and so
um that's part of what it's for and it's
not the end-all be-all in life but you
can use it to have access like what he's
saying to have options all of it so man
Matthew just bring in just bringing the
Thunder Matthew well done we love it
such a deep thinker he is I respect that
about mm
is that what you call him is that what
he was Matthew McConaughey when he was
on your show was he like Rachel you can
call me mm call me Eminem call me Maddie
he wasn't on my show Rachel we should
get him on Smart money happy hour to
talk about this great Matthew
McConaughey if you're listening I assume
that you're a big fan I know we were in
your top Spotify podcast get in touch
with our team we'd love to have you on
but it's true Rachel money magnifies
we've said that before it just makes you
more of what you are yep so if you're a
jerk and you're a miserable person well
man you're gonna be a rich jerk and if
you're generous while you don't have
much you're only going to become wildly
generous we call those people
philanthropists and so that encourages
me yeah and it can be different for you
if you're listening and you're feeling
that stress you're one of those people
who has cried who's at the panic attack
who's felt that lump in your throat the
knot in your stomach you can have what
we call Financial Peace but it starts
with deciding that enough is enough
we're gonna make some changes in our
life do whatever it takes draw the line
in the sand to change our family tree
and do something different and so
Financial Peace University the namesake
is one of the best ways to do that so be
sure to check that out we'll be back
with more of the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George camel
host of the fine print entree leadership
and co-host of smart money happy hour
joined by best-selling author Rachel
Cruz and we are here for you America to
help you with whatever you're dealing
with when it comes to money and life the
number to call is triple eight eight two
five five two two five Valerie is up
next in San Francisco Valerie welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hi George hi Rachel I'm so excited to
finally be talking to you guys we've
been waiting for you Valerie thank you
for calling in it's about time
what's going on okay I have a I just
have a quick question so
um I recently got I so I Tran
transitioned from being a part-time
employee to finally be able to be
full-time
um I just don't know how to readjust my
budget because that did come with extra
expenses extra expenses
yes okay so you got a raise going from
part-time to full time like what what's
your extra expenses
um so now I'm because I work all over
the Bay Area I'm wasting I'm not wasting
I'm using one on gas okay
um and then sometimes they do put us in
a hotel and some of the hotels are um
they require like deposits which
I've been prepared so far but I just
want to make sure I have enough that
aside to sure because they do hold on to
my money yep yep okay that's great so
yeah I mean I would just uh but
obviously it's going to come with more
income right you're yeah yes uh which is
a great thing what are you making
um so I'm I now have the potential to
make anywhere from 50 000 to 68 000.
which I'm on track to do all right and
do you have any debt
yes I do what are we talking I'm
so total I have about 29 000 left I have
been working your baby steps um I'm
still working on number two
um and then I don't have a mortgage so
it's roughly 11 000 on my car
um and then the rest would be so seven
thousand on the personal loan and then
the rest on credit cards okay
so that's your next goal obviously
you're in the middle of that and your
question is about kind of managing this
this extra money or managing the new
expenses does your new budget coming up
um yes my new budget especially for next
year
um so I'm still doing the minimum
payments on all the cards and everything
and then I am putting everything towards
my first one but I have found myself
having to use
um a credit card just
um for things that I didn't see coming
like that one time that I didn't know
that they were going to ask for a
deposit down
um I immediately paid that part off but
it does I want to make sure I have the
money set aside so that I don't have to
use my credit card so this sounds like
it could be a buffer issue in your
checking account as well how much money
do you have in there
at the moment about 150 . okay I would
increase that
um you might need to you know slow down
your debt payoff by just an inch but
have a little bit more maybe a 500
cushion in the checking account and you
make sure it never goes below 500 that's
kind of your your new zero
okay that'll probably help with these
deposit issues you're experiencing so
that you're not turning to the credit
card which by the way I would cut that
thing up so that you can't even use it
if you wanted to because right now it's
a rubber crutch
yes I I figured you'd tell me that yeah
because Valerie we want you to be your
emergency fund you know you're gonna
have your thousand dollars uh for baby
step one you'll have some cushion in
your checking account for when these
kind of expenses come up
um and then you're just gonna be yeah
really diligent about the budget and I
think
um just upping your gas you're you're
gonna be able to maybe estimate and say
okay I'm gonna have to fill up this many
more tanks of gas here's roughly what
it's going to be
um and and maybe you have a line item in
your budget that every month you kind of
just budget for those just in case
things you can call that miscellaneous
you can whatever it is but if you know
that there are expenses coming up put
those in the budget and so you're able
to kind of work around your life more
it's just it's more of that planning out
so if there is a deposit that you need
not only will you have the money and
you're checking out but even you're
planning for it in your budget what are
you currently using to make your budget
Valerie
I am using the every dollar app it's
just um I wasn't sure where to put the
like the the deposit fees into like what
area yeah it is temporary so you can
make the line item for hotel deposits
and if you know hey roughly I go to two
hotels it's about 200 a time well that
money's coming back but for now it helps
you track it and I'm gonna gift you one
year of our premium version of every
dollar so that it connects to your bank
account which will make this even easier
how does that sound
amazing awesome we're happy to do that
too I love that you are like so focused
on this baby step too you're gonna do
whatever it takes and I think this
little buffered issue will sort itself
out and you'll be back on track We are
rooting for you great job Valerie yeah
thanks for the question hang on the line
Austin will pick up and we'll gift you
one year of every dollar premium all
right our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they're 100 satisfaction
guarantee means even if you mismeasure
or you pick the wrong color they will
remake your blinds for free you get free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they'd run every month you'll
save even more be sure to use the promo
code Ramsay to get the best deal and
today's question comes from Maxine in
Texas I only recently found you all and
on vacation last week I bought The Total
Money Makeover and read it in one night
and finally excited that I can make a
better future for myself thank you my
question is when will it be appropriate
for me to buy a dog my last dog had
numerous surgeries and was quite
expensive and I've learned since the
last experience ways that might reduce
the expenses but there is no guarantee
or dog people
I've got two you've got one one yes okay
but you've had dogs your whole life yeah
yeah they've been sharing our dog people
yeah and what's fun Rachel we just did
an episode on the Rachel Cruise show you
and I about pets and how much here's
what's called how much having a pet is
actually costing you and we kind of
broke down the math and we had some hot
takes of kind of like hey if you're
really broke it may not be the best time
to get a pet because your pet deserves a
good life you know doesn't that real
life of luxury but you got to be able to
afford the vet visits and the food and
the right kind of care and so I don't
tell people hey wait till you're
completely out of debt if you're gonna
get a pet right right that's not the
spirit of this yeah and you want to be
able to say okay reasonably what breed
because even breeds are have a different
cost you know that I have French cheese
what are they called designer dogs yeah
George has two and people are very
Rachel the adopt don't shop people have
come at me well because I was gonna say
there are a lot of dogs that you can
adopt for free there are but they got
mad at you yeah like French Bulldogs
healthily bred are really you can't just
find those at shelters sure as you know
it's like trying to find a Gucci purse
at a Goodwill like can you find it maybe
but it's rare and so we decided we had
the money we budgeted for it and we
wanted this specific big dog that's
right anyways when will it be
appropriate for me to buy a dog when you
can afford it and I don't know your your
financial situation all we know is that
you're on vacation and you've got to
throw the money makeup I know well and I
think you know mapping out when it's
when it's a purchase like this just map
out roughly okay you know how much food
is this dog gonna do some research on
the breed you're looking at or if it's a
you know a dog from the shelter you can
do rough math to say okay it's going to
cost probably this much some food a
month uh how often do they need their
their shots and their vaccines like what
are we gonna need pet sitters if we go
out of town you know you can kind of run
some scenarios and get a f you know an
estimate on what it costs per month
um but yeah I mean there are and then
there becomes a budget line item yes you
gotta make sure you have that and also
on the emergency fund side I don't want
you using your personal human emergency
fund and draining it for the dog and so
I like having a separate little pile of
money for the dog like a little sinking
fund for the animals and so that can be
a great way to separate this out and go
I'm going to put 50 bucks a month into
the sinking fund for the animal are you
a pet insurance person we talked about
that on the show that's right and I've
crunched the numbers we had it for a
season like a Wellness Plan type thing
but as I found the insurance companies
almost always win and rarely is it going
to be worth it and so you're better off
just taking that amount you were paying
every month and putting it into that
interesting event and so it's really
hard to like beat the system when it
comes to these uh pet insurance
companies so largely it's just not worth
it yeah and some of them there's like a
Wellness Plan type thing some of those
may be okay but don't fall for for the
schemes skills but yeah I mean we love
dogs and you can do it very cheaply and
it can be very expensive so there's a
large Spectrum but the key is know what
you're getting into save for it budget
for it do it all in cash and make sure
that you're prepared for an emergency
great question thank you so much for it
Maxine uh send us a picture of that of
that sweet pup once you get them more of
your calls coming up triple eight eight
two five five two two five is the number
to call this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show folks if
you've gone through FPU Financial Peace
University the chances are it's because
someone in your life lit the fire under
your butt mom and dad gave it to you as
a gift your pastor offered it at your
church or that one friend wouldn't stop
talking about sorry is this what that
said that's literally what it says
lights a fire yeah that's how it works
it's a lot to get someone to change
their money life is that what I just
heard okay keep going I can't make this
stuff up so you finally took the class
after maybe some some nodding some
prodding uh you started working these
baby steps and now everything is
different you've changed your entire
future and so now you can do the same
for someone else you can give someone
you care about Financial Peace
University and share that same hope
you've discovered with money and with
Christmas coming this is the perfect
time to do it and when you give FPU as a
gift they're going to get more than just
the course they'll get the premium
version of every dollar so they can
start living on a budget they'll join in
on group calls with our team of
financial coaches and so much more so
this Christmas give the people you care
about a gift that actually matters and
that's hope that is freedom so if you
want to buy FPU as a gift go to
ramseysolutions.com give FPU that's
ramseysolutions.com
it is a great gift to be I mean really I
mean it's like it feels weird because
like I'm gonna gift them like a thing
that's like get better with money yeah
no but it's like here's the thing that's
that that's gonna that helps in general
regardless of whether you feel like
you're great with money or not so and
you can also always pair it with another
little gift too to make it less of a
focus if that's if that's a worry for
you a concern but it really is it's a
great gift and it is the gift that keeps
on giving because if they become debt
free because of that that gift paid
dividends it's awesome so go check that
out all right back to the phones we go
Nate joins us up next in Grand Rapids
Michigan Nate welcome to the show
hey how are we doing good how are you
good good love all you guys love
listening to you guys oh we appreciate
that how can we help today
the question is I heard you guys talking
earlier about uh if you're in debt not
to be investing in uh like your match
for your company at Sonic or your 401k
correct company and I currently am and
I'm in debt obviously
um so I was wondering should I stop
investing and then kind of like a little
second question and then should I take
what I have in my 401k and help speed
ball and take it out to knock down my
debt or just keep plugging away and
snowballing it the way I'm doing it now
the latter for sure do not pull any
money any money out of your 401k because
it comes with a whole bunch of penalties
and fees and unplugging all the growth
so if you've been investing it's okay
just pause that and begin to use that
extra cash flow that you now have to
attack that debt aggressively
okay yeah because the reason is Nate the
why behind that is we've just found when
you can focus on one thing with your
money uh you make progress so much
faster and then the benefit of being out
of debt that much faster is that you
don't have payments so then you're able
to say okay I can save up actual cash
and have an emergency fund which is baby
step three and then once all of that's
taken care of it's like you have this
really solid Financial Foundation of no
payments and emergency funds and then
you can go press play and invest 15 of
your income into retirement so into that
401K Roth IRA and using those those
retirement vehicles to build that wealth
and I love the fire it kind of Lights
under you when you're going I'm missing
out on the match I really want to get
back to that match so I'm going to get
out of debt even faster the problem is a
lot of people get comfortable because
they're doing seven things at once and
they're like ah I'm okay and so I
actually love the fact that we tell
people to pause all investing because it
is for folks that have a hard time with
it it's because they want to see that
money grow but you kind of have a house
built on Sand when you got a pile of
debt not a lot of money in the bank you
owe people money it's just a scary place
to be yeah how much debts you have Nate
I'm just curious
[Music]
35
000. okay I got how much do you make a
year
anywhere from 80 to 100 okay so yeah you
can knock this debt out quickly and I
got about 11
000 in emergency fund in my savings oh
okay yeah well I would I would drain
that down throw some of that money
um how's the 35 divided the debt is it
cars um I got I got about 8 500 and uh
student loan and then the rest I know
you guys are yeah I mean I took a HELOC
out to consolidate some other debt and I
got about 25
000 on that on that okay I mean I'd pay
off your student loan today Nate I mean
I would go ahead and just get what's the
payment on knock that out
uh the payment month actually just upped
it because I paid off another thing so
I'm paying about 180 a month on it right
now okay
so yeah it's not going to free up like a
ton a ton but yeah I would go ahead and
knock that out so it's freed up then you
got that extra like yeah 180 a month
plus other stuff to throw at the HELOC
at the 25 and you could get it I mean
yeah you could be out in the next year
really quick Nate and then save up some
cash for an emergency fund and then
press play on that investing and how old
are you
36. yeah yeah I mean that's plenty of
what I would do I mean and it's awesome
I got my house sorry and I guess I
forgot my house dead I got that down to
147
000 and I got it on a 15-year note and I
just got about 13 years left that's
great well what we found is people doing
the baby steps uh that once they've paid
off their consumer debts they get their
emergency fund they invest in retirement
they actually are paying off their house
on an average in seven years it's
amazing so you're gonna just have so
much income freed up and and then it
kind of gets addicting where you're like
oh my gosh what if I didn't have a
mortgage and and going after that so uh
so yeah I'm excited for you these these
numbers look really promising I am now
the addiction's getting to me because I
just been paying off a couple other
smaller ones yeah it's really getting to
me I love it I love it well congrats now
hey thanks for calling yeah Rachel this
is a big thing people struggle with
because they do the math on paper and
they're like well Rachel wouldn't make
more sense to get the free money in the
match and watch this money grow but we
found that personal finance says eighty
percent Behavior it's only twenty
percent head knowledge and so math on
paper only goes so far to actually
change the way we behave when it comes
to money which is a much bigger Factor
than just math alone that's right
changing our and changing your habits
and again for some people it's
uncomfortable to say hey we're going to
pause investing to pay off that debt but
even even that being uncomfortable is
good for you do you know what I'm saying
like if you keep doing the same thing
you've been doing comfortable is how we
got here you're going to keep getting
the same result and so there's something
about just shaking up the whole thing
changing your habits completely changing
the way you've been viewing your money
you're going to get a completely
different result which is our goal good
stuff all right Trista joins us up next
in Minneapolis Trista welcome to the
show
hi thank you for having me absolutely
how can we help today
um I am through baby step three I just
started
um my kids's
um education savings account and we're
turning on our 401 again awesome but
lately to the last year I've been making
double mortgage payments because we're
in a house right now but it's not we're
looking to move in the next two years so
my question basically is should I keep
making double payments and throw more
Equity into the home or should I be
putting that into this like a sinking
fund for a deposit on another house
I would continue making those double
payments I mean it's a forced savings
plan and here's what that means the
money you would put elsewhere might get
used elsewhere uh because then you're
like well we could upgrade this and you
know we could go on that vacation paying
it into the mortgage is a great idea
because when you go to sell that house
it's sitting there inside of the equity
and you're paying less towards interest
every month on that mortgage so there's
all the reasons I've I have done that
and continue to advise people to do it
okay that's kind of what I was thinking
of I just wanted to make sure before I
change anything because yeah you're
doing great and congratulations how much
longer until you pay off the house
I I think it's like uh 2032
so 10 years from now but you're looking
to move before then right yeah that
might change some things yeah that's
great that's awesome I'm finishing
college and and we're going to be
getting more income in the next couple
years so we just want to move into a
bigger home for our family
way to go how old are you two
uh 32 and 37. that is awesome great job
I love this like just young people
getting a hold of this stuff going like
hey what if we didn't have a mortgage
forever how about that baby steps four
through six right there she's doing it
it's awesome we have I've seen a trend
with our debt-free screamers we're
getting young people who aren't just
paying off Consumer Debt but their house
paying off their house in their 20s and
30s yeah it's crazy because their
parents taught them they went through
Financial Peace University yeah they got
them on board and they're like oh I
didn't know that I didn't have to live
with a payment forever and so those are
very inspiring because there could be a
whole new generation Rachel of people in
their 20s and 30s with no debt not even
a mortgage payment it's amazing who are
just Building Wealth and giving
outrageously that's inspiring It's A
Beautiful World you just changed your
country I'm here for it I want to live
in that world and you guys are a part of
it by following this plan by doing the
hard work and we are so so proud of you
keep it up
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show our scripture of
the day comes from Proverbs 12 16. a
fool shows his annoyance at once but a
prudent man overlooks an insult Leslie
Knope from Parks and Rec said one
person's annoying is another's inspiring
and heroic
good and that Proverbs one was that hit
me personally Rachel that that's
basically saying like hey maybe don't
respond to the YouTube comments that's
what Proverbs was saying two words
earlier I know it's widely known and the
team's like be yourself on social media
you know and George was like well if I
am myself I want to jump into the
comments and stir up a Ruckus I just I
gotta stand up to the bullies Rachel as
someone who was like low-key bullied
when I was younger yeah I'm not taking
it as an adult I'm gonna raise my fist
and yeah get back at him I'm
intellectually stronger than they are
maybe not physically but that's social
media oh well uh on a on a brighter note
if we look into the lobby of Ramsay
Solutions we are getting ready for an
exciting moment because Santa is coming
to the Ramsay HQ and the Ramsay team
members are bringing their kids to meet
Santa not just Santa is Mrs Claus here
too there are two Christmas Thrones
right now on the depth stage so I'm
assuming assuming that there's gonna be
both and we have 1100 people that work
here and majority you know I'd say a
majority of them have kids yeah so
there's about to be a lot of kids in the
lobby of Ramsey solution you get to meet
Santa you get a free photo St Nick how
cool is that I might get a photo with
Santa before I leave today just just say
I met the guy I know him Jolly Old Saint
Nick I love I hope he doesn't smell like
beef and cheese that's the goal
it's a tradition here at Ramsay and uh
we love it we love it there's gonna be a
lot of Christmas cheer in our lobby
today all right let's go back to the
phones Sam joins us in Houston Texas uh
Sam welcome to the show how are you
doing buddy
uh pretty good pretty good how about
yourselves we are doing uh swimmingly
how can we help today
so um I just finally became debt free
in my student loans my credit cards
that's awesome now I'm just trying to
figure out what do I do like I I just
retire man
and I'm just like what do I do like it's
oh how much did you pay off
I paid off 9 000 of student loans then 9
000 of credit cards good for you so
great
um all right well tactically what do you
do you move on baby step three have you
been saving for an emergency fund
I already have that taken care of this
paycheck uh finishes my three to six
months of savings great job Sam we're
clapping for you so then we're gonna be
a baby step four investing 15 of our
income into retirement
okay and beyond that I'm guessing you
don't have kids
uh no I don't I don't have kids okay how
old are you
I'm 26. awesome and you're single
married
uh single for right now okay well the
good news is you have a lot of life
ahead of you and life costs a lot of
money including engagement rings and
weddings and houses are you are you
currently a homeowner or are you renting
uh currently I actually live with my
parents so uh and I also don't have a
car so I'm just trying to figure out
like what should I do first oh yeah
there's some goals for a car like
um
it's like yeah getting a vehicle have
you looked at kind of what kind of car
you'd want and how much you can afford
um I I've been looking at cars they're
just really expensive I mean
realistically before this car craziness
I just wanted a Honda Accord yes the
same as my kind of guy a Honda man how
much do you make a Year Sam
I make 60 a year 60 okay well listen
cars yeah I mean brand new ones are
gonna cost you yeah but you can go get a
used car could you get a fifteen
thousand dollar Honda Accord
yeah I mean I I just got to look for it
because the ones are charging 15 000 are
I've seen 2010s they have like 180 000
miles so I'm like I I know Hondas are
great but I don't know how much life out
of 200 000 they have well I would I
would do a dollar amount Sam and say hey
here's you know whatever you want to
save 15
000 17 000 whatever it is and then look
to see what cars are in that range
because they're still great cars Honda
Civics obviously are wonderful but
there's other great uh Great Cars
besides that Toyota Camrys you know you
could go along the list if you just want
a reliable car and you can find those
Sam that aren't going to cost you a time
like an autotrader.com and sort and buy
your zip code and filter it by Price
yeah and you can even negotiate with
folks on Facebook Marketplace or
Craigslist but make sure to do a
pre-purchase inspection when it comes to
a used car to do your due diligence
because you're buying these cars as is
which means as soon as you drive that
thing off the lot if anything goes wrong
there's no gun on back
right so Sam I think you're so to answer
your question why you called I would be
investing 15 of my income into
retirement I would be taking any extra
cash to save up for this car
and then once you have your car then my
next goal is to move out of your parents
house and whether that's renting
somewhere for a little bit
um versus saving up a down payment but
um yeah yeah I would probably rent while
saving up because you're 26 and you're
making great money you've done
incredible with your money this far and
like we said to a caller earlier on the
show there's just something Sam about
living on your own again living with
your parents for a time is not terrible
you know it's not like we're completely
against that but there is a level of
dignity for you that there's just
something about taking care of yourself
that you're in charge of paying the
bills you you look at money even a
little differently even with that
um you know the food situation you look
in the refrigerator you're like oh it's
up to me to get the eggs I need bread it
just it there's just this percentage of
that extra dignity and adulthood that
you experience which I think is really
healthy and and who knows even where the
motivation can be out of that within
your job and it changed changes the way
maybe even you work and maybe you get a
raise I don't know there's just there's
a lot of Ripple effects out of that so
that would be after you get the car my
next goal would be to move out rents for
a little bit and start saving up for a
down payment on a home if that's where
that's where you want to go yeah that's
huge and every single person listening
right now if you're going okay what's
next for me what are my goals a great
way to filter it is through our seven
baby steps where we say get a thousand
dollar emergency fund get out of
consumer day get the emergency fund
fully funded three to six months start
investing 15 percent save for kids
college pay off the house early build
wealth and give that's kind of the
open-ended piece of the puzzle but man
that's a journey right there it is and
so part of it is just making sure you
have those goals and as we head into a
new year it's that time where we all go
oh there's those resolutions from last
year that I never accomplished but I
want to encourage you guys at some point
someone said you know what this is going
to be the year that I actually do it I
actually become debt free I get that
emergency fund and uh Rachel and I and
Dr John deloney we created to this goal
planner to help folks with that to walk
alongside them with a lot of teaching
not just blank spaces to help you stay
focused on those goals with your money
your faith your relationships areas you
definitely want to be focused in on but
we want to cheer you guys on this year I
want to see all of our callers
accomplish their goals yeah and we have
so many new listeners too I think
through the podcast and through YouTube
and just encourage you guys that if
you've not fully like
you know dove into this plan number one
it's proven we've proved it over 30
years
millions of people have gone through
this and it's incredible the freedom
that they've experienced we want that
for everyone but we always say that
first step that baby step one sometimes
it's the hardest step to take not
because it's saving up at that thousand
dollars but it's it's acknowledging okay
I'm gonna change the way I've been
handling my money and change is scary
George oh yeah when you're not used to
something there's the unknown it can
create a level of anxiety and it's like
I don't know if I want to engage this
because I even if what I'm doing I'm not
really happy with the end result at
least I'm comfortable because I know I
can predict what's going on the devil
you know to change it is hard and so I
just want to encourage all of you guys
that is like you're even cautious about
that first step just do it do the plan
for six months we're in December right
now I would say you know do it through
May May of 2023 and if you absolutely
hate it you can go back to whatever you
were doing before that's right but give
it some time and really come commit to
it and it's amazing what ends up
happening because common sense in the
truth will always prevail
that'll preach yeah you can't beat Davis
you gotta fully commit to the Ramsay
plan uh before you start yelling at us
that it didn't work okay there you go
good hour Rachel thank you so much to my
awesome co-host Rachel Cruz all of you
listening all the folks in the booth
Austin and will and James and Josh and
Andrew and Zach we're going to be back
with you America don't worry we'll be
back soon but until next time be sure to
spend wisely save intentionally and give
generously
foreign
[Music]
do you love a good day Brandt want to
see the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]